- Thank you very much.
How are you?
Hey, thank you very much,
this is so exciting.
So, we're gonna talk a
little bit about agents.
My name's Don Schuerman, I'm CTO at Pega.
We're AWS long-time
partner software company
based out of Boston, and
we do a lot of automation,
workflow automation,
decisioning automation
for some of the world's
largest organizations
and government agencies.
And if you've been out here today,
like you guys, everybody's
talking about agents,
everybody's very excited about agents.
I also talk to a lot of enterprise CIOs,
folks who run pretty big
regulated businesses,
and while they're excited about agents,
they're also a little
bit scared about agents.
Because if we're operating
in an agentic world
where an agent is getting
things right 90 to 95%
of the time, that's
disastrous if you are a bank,
if you are a life sciences company,
if you are a government agency
operating under regulations.
So, what we wanna talk
a little bit about today
is how can you build agents that operate
with a higher degree of predictability?
So you actually get them to do the things
you want them to do.
And that starts with
stepping back a little bit
and thinking about some of the technology
that underpins agents.
So, we start with agents,
but we have to go back
a little bit and talk a bit about AI.
And we have a tendency,
I think, as technologists
to talk about AI as
sort of one giant blob,
like there's a giant blob of AI
if you read a lot of the news coverage
that happens with AI.
But I think those of us who
have worked in the space
for over a decade know AI
actually isn't just one thing.
It's a bunch of different technologies
that solve different problems.
And I like to think about AI
in a couple different forms.
There's what I call AI decisioning.
This is AI that can use structured data
to find predictions, find relationships,
and then use those
predictions to make decisions,
like what's the best offer
to give to a customer?
Or how likely is this
process to miss its SLA.
And we do that in Pega.
In Pega, we have a product
called Customer Decision Hub,
which my colleagues over at our booth
would be happy to show you.
Amazon has been doing
this for a while, too.
We use their SageMaker models,
which are really decision-making,
predictive AI models
built on structured data.
Of course, over the last couple years,
we all got introduced to generative AI.
And generative AI introduced a whole bunch
of productivity tools for us.
We've probably all used Copilot.
I go to a lot less meetings these days
because I just wait for
the meeting to be recorded
and for somebody to email me the summary.
AWS has provided great tools with Bedrock
that we can use to build
these productivity solutions.
We've got 'em.
You can summarize any case in Pega.
You can use rag-based tools
to get at your knowledge.
You can have coaches that
recommend things to users.
And I think productivity tools are great.
But I also think a lot of
the AI productivity tools
are a lot like Microsoft Excel.
We would never hire an employee
that doesn't know how to use them,
but we actually aren't gonna
differentiate our business
through the use of AI productivity tools
because everybody's using the same tools.
So what I'm focused on and
what we're focused on at Pega
is how do I use AI to
drive transformation?
How do I use AI to make
my business better,
to make it different, to actually rethink
some of the business
processes and ways of working
and customer experiences that we deliver?
And we've been lucky
enough to partner with AWS
as the only ISV that was present
in their launch of AWS Transform,
their tools for modernizing mainframe
and Java and other applications.
And we've done that through a capability
that we call Gen AI Blueprint.
And Gen AI Blueprint uses
AI capabilities from AWS,
from organizations like Anthropic,
and some of the know-how
that Pega's built out
over the last couple of decades
of automating some of the
most complicated processes
in the world.
And we use it to help you
rethink your business processes
and then be able to apply
agents against those workflows.
Because what happens is
the workflow acts as music.
The workflow gives your agents a score
so that instead of playing random notes
and going off and doing random things,
they're actually operating
together in unison.
And I like to think about Blueprint
as sort of an AI or agentic composer
that helps write the kind of scores
that we need for our business to run,
regardless of the industry
you're working in,
regardless of the area
or domain in the business
that you're working in.
So that's enough from a slide perspective.
What I wanna do is quickly
actually show you Blueprint.
So this is Blueprint.
You can check it out.
You can go to pega.com/blueprint.
If that's hard to remember,
I'm gonna give you a QR code at the end.
You can also walk over to our booth
that is literally right
directly across from me,
and people will be happy
to show you Blueprint.
But again, you can do it yourself.
So when you log into Blueprint,
and again, all we're gonna
ask for with Blueprint
is your email address.
We're not gonna spam you.
We're not gonna use anything
you put into Blueprint
to train our data.
This is your tool for
thinking about your business
and how you wanna run it.
But you can come into Blueprint,
and you can first begin
by selecting an industry.
So somebody give me one of these.
What's an industry folks would
wanna do a Blueprint for?
Insurance, awesome.
All right, so we've
worked a lot in insurance
with clients like AIG
and Farmers and Allianz.
So we know that insurance
actually isn't just insurance.
There's different areas.
Any one of these particularly
interesting to you?
The first one, commercial
property and casualty.
So this is like actually
insuring businesses.
So building the insurance
process for businesses.
And actually inside of insurance,
I can type whatever I want here,
but let's deal with claims.
That sounds, makes sense, great.
Claims are always
interesting and complicated.
So now I describe a little bit more
about what I want this application to do.
So I could do end-to-end
claims management.
I'm gonna select first notice of loss.
So that's like the intake.
If something goes wrong,
you've got a fire at your pizza place.
You call your property
insurer and you say,
"Hey, I need to get my
pizza ovens replaced
"'cause I had a fire."
So related to new claims promoted,
focus on small business
owners like restaurants.
So maybe we've got a little bit of focus.
Well, let's do this for
an insurance company
that might offer this kind of stuff.
So let's, I'm just gonna
throw Farmers out here.
There we go, Farmers Group.
Oh, actually, sorry, Farmers Insurance
is the one that I want, but
we'll grab the right one.
Well, Farmers Group.
We'll go with Farmers Group, sorry.
And I can do this in different languages,
but I don't speak any of them well,
so I'm gonna do it in
English if that's okay.
And what happens now is Blueprint
starts going and doing searching.
It's looking at a rag-based database
that we have of industry best practices.
We also work with partners like Capgemini
and EY and Accenture,
and they actually have their
own versions of Blueprint
that have embedded some
of the best practices
that they've built.
It's also looking at some of the things
around the structure of
an enterprise application.
And what Blueprint has identified
is that in order to automate
the first notice of loss
for our insurance company,
I need to be doing a couple
of different types of workflows.
I need to be able to take in a claim.
I need to do a damage assessment.
I need to understand if there
was a business interruption.
So this is all stuff that
Blueprint has figured out
through AI and by looking at
understanding best practices
available either in our database or
in the broader internet.
And it suggested some workflows to you.
I can change these.
If I wanna edit them, if I
wanna add more, I can add more.
But from here, I'm just gonna go
and let Blueprint continue to work.
And it's now gonna take
each one of those workflows
that I defined, and it's gonna figure out
all of the steps of the workflow,
what's gonna be automated,
what's gonna be done by an agent,
what's gonna be done by a human.
It's gonna figure out
what are the data models
that need to run underneath
this application.
So what fields do I need to collect?
It's gonna suggest the
places where this application
would need to interface
with other data objects
like my policy admin system
that are gonna live
somewhere in my business.
It's gonna think about who the users
of this application are.
So who's gonna use this application
and what different types
of security privileges
and user experiences do they need?
And then it's gonna think
about all the channels
that I wanna have this
application running on.
So what Blueprint has now done, right,
and what, we've been doing
this for about two minutes,
right, Blueprint has now
actually created for me
a full application for
first notice of loss
for a commercial insurer.
So it understands how to intake a claim,
do things like verify policy information.
It basically has laid out
the business-specific steps
this workflow needs to do.
And if I wanna change the
order of these things,
I can drag and drop them around,
I can add steps, I can remove steps.
This is mine to configure at this point.
AI's made a whole bunch of suggestions,
but the end user gets
to make the decisions
of what is actually happening.
Blueprint's also figured
out the data model.
So what do I need to collect
in order to run this case?
It even suggests some business rules.
My AI's still running in the background,
but the Blueprint will actually suggest
business rules and decisions
and build you out decision tables
for what this application needs to do.
And it's done this not
just for one, right,
but it's done this for things like
my damage assessment process,
it's done this for anything
like business interruption
if I need to manage that.
So it's done this for the
full suite of my applications.
It's also figured out what's
the data model that I need,
right, so I need to go
get my policy information.
Now, my policy information is
probably not sitting in PEGA,
so I can go in and change that.
I can say that, no, actually
I want my policy information
that's gonna come out of
my policy admin system.
And so now we're building the data maps
of where this workflow
needs to interface out
to different systems.
In fact, if you come to
Blueprint with existing YAMLs,
right, so definitions of REST files,
if you come to Blueprint with
existing DDLs from databases,
we can just import those
directly into the Blueprint
and use them.
And then finally, the
Blueprint has figured out,
well, who are the people
who are gonna use this app.
So I'm gonna have a restaurant owner
who is probably gonna submit this,
my claims adjuster, the insurance agent
who needs to be notified,
my claims supervisor,
my risk assessor, all of that.
Cool, so now I've built this,
but here's the really cool thing.
If you've done a lot of sort of projects
and requirements gathering,
and you've got your business
people and your IT people,
and everybody's trying to get together,
too often you're operating in
sort of a state of blindness.
The business people don't really know
what they're gonna get
at the end of the day.
The IT people don't really actually know
what they have to build.
So we get project delays,
we get things that are inaccurate,
we get things that don't
actually deliver the value
that they were expected to deliver.
So the power of Blueprint
is that I can, right now,
I can actually run the application.
So this is now a running
prototype of my claims application,
where I can actually go through,
and I can intake a claim,
we're using AI to generate
a bunch of synthetic data
so that I can test this.
But I can literally step through
all the various stages
of my claims process.
I can do that not just in a desktop,
if I wanted to see what that
looks like on a mobile app,
I can preview that experience.
A lot of our clients are
Salesforce customers,
so we're often the workflow engine
sitting behind Salesforce.
So we've got a pre-built
Lightning component
where our workflow runs natively
inside of Salesforce Lightning,
so you can actually
see our workflow there.
We're also a contact center app,
so we show up in Gartner's Magic Quadrant
as a leader in the contact center space,
so I can embed all of these workflows
directly in a contact center app
that incidentally
integrates with AWS Connect,
so you can do your telephony that way.
We can do some self-service
if we wanna do it.
So I can embed this right
on the farmer's homepage.
But we talked about having
conversational agents.
So what I've done now,
and again, I haven't written any prompts,
I haven't done any coding,
but I now have a conversational agent
that can do work on my customer's behalf.
So if my customer comes in
and sells the agent that he had a fire
in the restaurant,
the agent is going to use the workflows
that we just built as
its collection of prompts
and data for what it can do.
And now it's gonna have a
conversation with the customer,
but the agent isn't randomly
figuring out what to do.
It's not doing a whole bunch
of reasoning at runtime.
It knows the workflows it needs to follow,
so it's going to now drive through
the exact process that it needs to do.
So it wants to know
when the fire occurred,
right, I'll type that in.
And behind the scenes,
we're just building out a case.
We're literally following the workflow
that I just defined
via AI two minutes ago.
And the cool thing is I
can use the agentic AI
to do things that the LLM
is really good at doing,
like semantically mapping
me to the right workflow
or changing the language
of the conversation that I wanna have.
All still the same workflow,
all being consistently executed,
but now allowing me to
have an agentic interface
into how you do it.
The other powerful thing
that we've built into Pega
is the ability not only
to have an agent come in
and call those workflows,
we do that, by the way, via MCP.
So if you wanna plug in
another agentic front end,
you certainly can.
This agent that I'm
running here supports A2A,
so if you wanted to connect it up
to one of your other agents, great,
they're all gonna work well together.
But we also can then
start embedding agents
at individual steps of the workflow.
So maybe I need an
agent that's really good
at validating photos
of the evidence, right,
and calculating a damage estimate.
Maybe I have an agent
that's good at identifying
a signature and validating
that the customer
has signed off on the claim
that they're submitting.
I can embed those agents in my workflow
so that I get more and more automation,
but because I'm restricting them
to an individual step of the workflow,
I don't have to worry
about them going haywire,
I don't have to worry about consuming
a bunch of tokens I don't need,
and I can treat the
agents the exact same way
I would treat a human.
I can quality check their work,
I can escalate to somebody else
if they can't get the work done properly.
So we provide that ability
to have both agents
on the top and agents on
the bottom of your workflow.
So that's Blueprint.
You can check it out yourself
at pega.com/blueprint,
you can go check it out at our booth.
The other thing that we're
beginning to see happen,
and what we've been thinking
a lot about at PEGA,
is where we think the world is going.
And I actually think that we're entering
a world increasingly where
our users and our customers
aren't gonna interact with applications
in the way that they used to.
Right, right now, the
way we make our users
interact with applications,
anybody ever walk
through a contact center?
Anybody ever spent time
inside a contact center?
Like the hellish life of a
contact center front end.
Oftentimes, contact center users will have
four, five, six different
applications they need to go to,
'cause they have one
application that does one thing,
and they have another
application do another thing.
And so often, we actually
put that experience
not only on our users, we
shove it out to our customers.
Where you have to call one number
if you wanna get one service,
and you gotta go talk to another group.
We're exposing our organization
and system silos to our customers.
And I actually think one
of the big transformations
that agents are gonna drive
is a lot of that complexity
can now be hidden.
Because instead of
thinking of our business
as a collection of applications
that a user needs to switch between,
I wanna increasingly
think about my business
as a catalog, a fabric.
And that fabric consists of workflows,
things that I can do on
behalf of my employee
or on behalf of my customer.
That fabric consists of knowledge.
What do I know that could
answer a question for them.
What kind of things are
covered by my insurance policy?
And that fabric consists of data.
What are the actual pieces of information
that a customer might wanna see?
What was my last bill on my policy?
When is it due.
And if I can take and
make that fabric available
and weave those workflows together,
we do this through what we call
our agentic process fabric,
I can now allow a customer
to have a single point in
to all of the workflows in the business,
whether the workflows live in Pega
or frankly, whether the
workflows live somewhere else.
Whether that data happens to live in Pega,
whether that data lives in Redshift,
whether that data lives in Databricks,
whether that data lives somewhere else.
And as we are increasingly
working with our partners at AWS
with the transform tool,
our partners like Capgemini,
who recently announced a
composable marketplace offering
to modernize Lotus Notes, Accenture,
who just announced a
composable marketplace offering
with us in transform to
modernize mainframe applications.
We're gonna be able to accelerate the path
for a lot of our clients
to take what are outdated,
siloed mainframe experiences
and bring them into this
modern agentic future.
And that's the future that
we think is gonna happen.
It's gonna be driven by agents.
It's gonna be governed
and bounded by workflows.
It's gonna deliver better experiences,
but it's gonna be in
the predictable fashion
that businesses demand.
So that's how you can pretty quickly
start deploying predictable
agents in your enterprise.
What I would encourage you, though,
is the great thing about
Blueprint is you can test it out.
You can try out the experience.
You can throw your own process into it.
You could do, you know,
blueprint a business process
like we do with claims.
You could blueprint,
I blueprinted my daughter's
college application process
recently, right, to kind
of get my some sense
of sort of what that's gonna look like.
But try it out.
Offer us any feedback.
Come see us at the booth over there.
We're really excited to be
partnering with AWS on this,
and we look forward to driving
a lot of transformation
over the next couple of years.
So thank you all very much.
Thanks for spending the time.
(audience applauds)